Let's go to Indiana, because
these pictures are just stunning
That's where we begin this morning
A huge fire
emitting toxic smoke
at a recycling plant
in the town of Richmond.
Watch this
now.
And can you imagine
standing there filming this
like this person did?
The flames
prompting officials
to issue
evacuation orders
for about 2000 people there.
Unknown plastics are burning
at the plant,
sending a giant pillar of black
all over Richmond.
Officials are now waiting on air
monitoring test results to help
how long people are going
to have to stay evacuated.
Firefighters say
when they responded to the scene
they discovered a semi-trailer
engulfed in flames
It was fully loaded
with unknown type of plastics.
The fire spread from the semi-tr
to other piles of plastics that
around the trailer.
We only have one access into the
where the fire was.
All the other access
roads were blocked
by piles of plastic
and other semi-trailers.
So the obvious question
this morning is how did this sta
Officials say they don't know
and they won't know
until that fire is extinguished.
They say it could burn for days.
Omar Jimenez is live on the scen
Omar, we can see you wearing a m
I heard you at a news conference
a short time ago.
What are they telling you
about the air quality right now?
Yeah, Don,
when it comes to the air quality
the concern here is particulates
from smoke matter at this point.
Obviously, in the plume itself,
They say that
that is where the toxicity is.
But as far as the ground level a
which of course, is
what people would be breathing,
the smoke is the real issue.
So that's part of
why we're wearing this mask.
I want to give you a glimpse of
this fire is looking at in the d
You can see the epicenter of sor
where this fire has been burning
This is where a lot of the fire
crews have been placing
some of their attention
throughout the morning.
They have been placing
a lot of water here.
They've now moved to a separate
part of the area itself.
When we talk about
what is actually burning,
as we understand,
at first
it was a semi-trailer
full of plastics that was on fir
Those flames eventually
spread to some piles of plastic.
And then eventually this compoun
the fire chief said in particula
this compound in total is about
worth of plastic inside.
And then about 13 and a half acr
have burned so far.
At this point,
we just got a briefing
from a whole host of officials
at the State level,
local level and federal level,
as well
as some representatives from the
But take a listen
to one of those officials
as they explained
a little bit of what they
are dealing with here.
These are very fine particles.
And if they're breathed,
then can cause all kinds
of respiratory problems
burning of the eyes
tightening of the chest.
It could aggravate asthma,
they could cause bronchitis
and all kinds of things.
So we are stress ing to the publ
to honor the evacuation zone.
It's for your safety
that the evacuation zone is ther
And if you can see the smoke,
you're in the smoke.
Get out of the smoke.
And as of now,
the evacuation
zone is about a half mile radius
from these flames.
About 2000 people in this.
35,000 person town
have been affected by those orde
To be clear,
one of the things
that fire officials did say
is that the fire
the good news is contained at th
To the recycling plant
itself, the fire itself
not spreading into the neighborh
but more clearly,
the smoke and the air quality is
So just you know, again,
we see you there.
I see the smoke behind you.
What's it like to be there?
Yeah, at this point, you know,
there is a smell in the air.
Obviously, you can't go far
without seeing this in particula
And we were talking to a residen
who lives in that evacuation zon
who literally got the order,
did not hesitate and left.
And even if she had not gotten t
if she just looked outside,
she would have seen that thick p
of black smoke.
She's essentially right in it.
Take a listen
to some of
what she told us earlier this mo
When they said evacuate,
I did have shoes on.
I had socks on
and I left my purse, my shoes.
I left a lot of things, personal
you know, at the house
and just got in the car and drov
I'm still worried
because they're telling us
they don't know what was burning
and that, you know, irritation o
skin problems.
You know,
and my eyes were kind of like ma
And I put warm clothes on that.
I didn't go to the hospital, but
it's available for us.
Right now.
And the mayor told us that today
the the focus is on the resident
but also the first responders
who are in there
actually battling this blaze.
But when you talk about
what may have caused this,
we still don't know what that is
at this moment.
But the mayor here was not minci
and said that the building
owner, the owner of this propert
is the one that is responsible f
because he says they've had issu
with this property before,
that they've been cited
before, that there were firehous
hazards sited on this location
and that this location had been
an order that they were unsafe.
And to use
some of the words of the fire ch
They did not wonder
if something like this would hap
but when and now it appears it h
So we're trying
to find more details on that.
But the mayor,
the fire chief, did not hold bac
when they pointed the blame very
even in these initial stages.
And I should also mention as wel
the fire chief said
the most difficult part
about getting to this
was that
a lot of the entrances were bloc
with debris of plastic.
So one of their initial problems
was just trying to be able
to get to the property
to fight this flame
that obviously
you can see from miles away here
More ominous
in Richmond, Indiana,
with the smoke billowing behind
Omar, you and your team, please
with us.
Now, is CNN chief
medical correspondent Dr. Sanjay
Sanjay, look,
plastic's a funny word
when it's in the film like The G
but when you're
talking about 14 acres of it bur
what are the risks it poses
to air quality
Well, you know,
there's the
way of looking at this as you ge
look at this
in the immediate
sort of time period,
but also sort of over time.
What happens to these
these particular compounds
and over space,
meaning that
the obviously
the evacuation zone is of concer
but we're talking about very,
very fine particles
which can travel over distance.
So over time
and space is when you have to so
think about this.
Omar was talking
about the particulate matter
in the evacuation zone.
That's the smoke.
That's the obvious stuff, John.
You know, you see it, you smell
you breathe it in. It's irritati
That's why
people need to get out of their
Can be helpful.
But really, as Omar was saying,
leaving that area
so you're not actually breathing
in that particulate matter,
which can affect even healthy pe
lungs and hearts
is is the sort of most immediate
I think what Omar was sort of al
and what you heard in
that presser as well,
is that when you burn this stuff
turn into
what are known as volatile
organic compounds.
That's sort of a potpourri
of all sorts of different things
It becomes hard to sort of pinpo
exactly what
that's all going to turn into
from previous fires
and sort of looking at
these types of compounds.
They know that it can turn into
like styrene or benzene.
And there's some
evidence of what that can do
if people are exposed.
But what happens now
right now, John, is that those c
that are so light
and so volatile,
they get up higher, much higher
in the plume that Omar was descr
And then over time,
they will start to dissipate
and come down to lower lying are
How long that takes where they l
Exactly.
That's a little bit of an unknow
I mean, because you have to
sort of anticipate and predict
how that's going to unfold.
But those you know,
those can be
potentially problematic compound
if they are in high enough doses
still at that point
when they come down to the groun
causing things like dizziness
and disorientation,
and confusion, headaches, things
like that, skin irritation.
There's a lot more that's known
about benzene, for example,
versus styrene.
But these are the sort of things
they're going to be looking for,
measuring the levels,
but also seeing
if there's any health impacts,
you know, over the next several
Who is most vulnerable here?
Are we talking about people
with respiratory issues or asthm
Who should be most careful
You know, really,
there's been these studies
that have looked at people
who have underlying health condi
such as cardiovascular disease.
People are at risk of heart dise
Things like that, babies.
But really, you know,
if you look
at some of these studies, John,
anybody is potentially vulnerabl
Healthy people.
There were studies of healthy pe
who had been near, you know, big
sort of plumes of smoke like thi
And certainly that particulate m
just think of that as smoke.
Breathing it in
anyone is particularly vulnerabl
when it comes to these volatile
organic compounds,
which, again,
maybe high up in that plume of s
may travel may come down over th
several days.
You know, people
who are at risk of that, again,
anybody could be at risk.
But people who have underlying
conditions, specifically
cardiac and respiratory,
they're going to
probably be the most at risk.